ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SUU KYI
THIS AREA IN WHEN O'DONNELL S.
IN PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TAKING BALLOT THERE IS V.
ABUJA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS
WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS
ACROSS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAYS PRIOR WE OFFER
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA FOOD
WALK. BIGNESS RIGOR LET US PRAY.
INTERNAL ARE YOUR MEMORIES OH
LORD YOUR GRAYSON STANNIS
THROUGHOUT EVERY DIFFICULTY AND
SUPPLIES ARE NEEDED HEARTS WITH
ENCOURAGEMENT. GIVE US THE
WISDOM FOR THE WORK THAT IS
BEFORE US. COM OR ATTITUDES
BLESSES WITH THE STRENGTH TO DO
THE WORK FOR THIS NEW DAY THIS
NEW WEEK THIS NEW YEAR. A MET.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING TO JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. SALUTE
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION- UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
MARCH TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ASSEMBLY MINUTE SEVENTY M.
THE ON HIS ADDRESSES IN THIS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF THE BILL WILL
BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR%
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR TODAY FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BARKHANE FOREIGN AND QUIRK. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAN
FOR ILLNESS IN THE FAMILY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN. MEMBERS
TODAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLIES BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WISHING HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
ADDITIONALLY TOMORROW IS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN IS
CELEBRATING A BIRTHDAY PLEASE
JOIN US IN WISHING HIM A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AS WELL. AND. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW SIMPLY MEMBERS GALLAGHER
CARILLO CHIU AND TAKING TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH WILL BE THE ORDER. MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY GO FORTY TWO. ALTHOUGH
THE BE DEEMED READ AND ALL
MEMBERS WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED
WILL BE NOW NOT BE MOVING TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM TO ACR TWENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BE APPROVED
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VEHICLE ABOUT RELATIVE TO
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY SUICIDE
PREVENTION AWARENESS DAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BE A HOTEL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE ACR
TWENTY THREE PROCLAIMING MARCH
EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE S. CONSTRUCTION SUICIDE.
PREVENTION AWARENESS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. SUICIDE IS A
COMPLEX PHENOMENA. AND A
SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM
THAT DEMANDS OUR ATTENTION
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF MENTAL HEALTH.
SUICIDE IS THE TENTH LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH OVERALL IN THE
U. S. AND SECOND LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH. TO THOSE UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTY FOUR AND FOURTH
LEADING COSTS TO THE DEATH OF
THOSE THIRTY FIVE TO FIFTY
FOUR. ACCORDING TO THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY ALLIANCE
OF SUICIDE PREVENTION SUICIDE
RATE IN CONSTRUCTION
OCCUPATIONS. IS FORTY NINE
POINT FOUR PER 1-000-100-1000
THAT IS NEARLY FOUR TIMES
GREATER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF FIVE TIMES GREATER
THAN. THAT OF ALL OTHER
CONSTRUCTION FACILITIES
COMBINED WITH THIS IN MIND HI I
PARTNERED UP WITH THE ASSOCIATE
SOCIAIS SHOULD BUILDERS AND
CONSTRUCTION ABC OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE TRUTH INTRODUCED AC
TWENTY THREE. BOB BRINGING
AWARENESS TO THE ISSUES
AFFECTING THOUSANDS OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. AND TO
REMIND CONSTRUCTION
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO OUR TO
POWER IN PREVENT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LEAD TO THE
TO COMMITTING SUICIDE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE- THE STIGMAS
TIES THE CONVERSATION AROUND
SUICIDE AND SHINE THE LIGHT ON
RESOURCES AVAILABLE SO ALL
CALIFORNIANS KNOW THAT HELP IS
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE IN NEED
THEY ARE ENCOURAGED TO CALL THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION.
LIFELINE AT ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
TWO SEVEN THREE TALK OR TEXT
HELLO. TWO SEVEN FOUR ONE EIGHT
SEVEN FOUR ONE. I AM HOPE
HOPEFULLY THAT THE ACE AC
TWENTY THREE IS IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP TO SUPPORTING OUR STATE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BY. RISING
AWARENESS ABOUT SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR THOSE WORKING IN
THE VITAL INDUSTRY WITH THIS IN
MIND I RESPECTFULLY YOURS
RESPECT THAT THE ROLL CALL BE
OPEN TO CO AUTHORS. THANK YOU
AS A MEMBER OF THE APPROVED
WHAT. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE NUMBERS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED OF THE.
A CALL THE ROLL THERE ARE FIFTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADAM WE WILL
NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. HOLD THE POSE THEY
KNOW. YOU GUYS HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING
THE FILE ITEM THREE HR TWENTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN THE
CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AREA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO NUMBERS. SEMINARIAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT HR TWENTY
AND RECOGNITION OF THE PERSIAN
NEW YEAR NOTICE. THIS
RESOLUTION PROCLAIMS THE
TRADITIONAL PERSIAN NEW YEAR
BEGINNING ON THE VERNAL EQUINOX
AND CELEBRATES THE FIRST DAY OF
SPRING AS NOTICE. IN DOING SO
THIS THREE THOUSAND YEAR OLD
TRADITION CONTINUES TO EXTEND
ITS HOPE FOR PEACE SOLIDARITY.
AND NEW BEGINNINGS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS NOTO'S IS A
COMBINATION OF TWO FARSI WORDS
THE FIRST WORD NO. MEANS NEW
AND THE SECOND WORD RUSE MEANS
DAY TOGETHER THE WORD MEANS NEW
DAY WHICH IS THE NAME GIVEN FOR
THE NEW YEAR IN THE PERSIAN
CALENDAR. NOTICES CELEBRATED
AND OBSERVE PRINCIPALLY IN IRAN
BUT HAS EXTENDED TO OTHER PARTS
OF THE WORLD INCLUDING STATE
MOST OF CENTRAL ASIA. FOR
PERSIAN AMERICANS AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHO OBSERVE NOTICE IT IS
A TIME TO CELEBRATE THEIR
HERITAGE. IT GIVES ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
ETHNIC CULTURAL RELIGIOUS OR
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH HOPE FOR A
NEW PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR. THE
DAY'S FOCUS ON RECONCILIATION
AND NEIGHBOURLINESS CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO CULTURAL
INCLUSIVENESS AND COOPERATION
AMONG PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. THIS MESSAGE OF
CELEBRATION AND HOPE IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AT A TIME
FRAUGHT WITH ANTI IMMIGRANT
SENTIMENT. H. R. TWENTY
CELEBRATES NEW BEGINNINGS
REBIRTH AND NEW LIFE. I ASKED
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AS A MEMBER OF THE SYRIAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY AND WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBER FROM VAN
NUYS FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
TO OUR FLOOR I'M PROUD THAT I
LIKELY REPRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY. A
LARGER NUMBER OF PERSIAN
AMERICANS THAN ANY OTHER MEMBER
ON THIS FLOOR. AND EACH YEAR
THE MEMBER FROM VAN NUYS BRINGS
FORWARD A RESOLUTION TO
RECOGNIZE THIS IMPORTANT
OCCASION SOMETHING WE SHOULD
ALL BE GRATEFUL FOR. HOWEVER I
CANNOT THINK OF A TIME WHEN WE
NEEDED TO EXPERIENCE AND
REFLECT UPON THE MEANING AND
PURPOSE OF NO ROSE MORE THAN
RIGHT NOW. AS OUR COLLEAGUE HAS
JUST MENTIONED NO RUZ MEANS NEW
DAY. AND IT SYMBOLIZES
SPRINGTIME RENEWAL PEACE AND
OVERALL FELT SOLIDARITY BETWEEN
GENERATIONS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY ARE IN NEED OF A NEW
DAY AFTER WEATHERING THE
TREMENDOUS LOSS GRIEF AND
TURMOIL THAT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
WROUGHT. WE NEED A NEW DAY IN
THE GEOPOLITICS OF THE WORLD
WHERE WE SEE SO MUCH VIOLENCE
AND STRIFE. AND WE NEED A NEW
DAY IN A WORLD OF THAT'S FILLED
WITH HATRED. AND WE NEED A NEW
DAY SO THAT WE CAN SEE THAT
HATRED DISAPPEAR. IT MAY BE
DIFFICULT AT THIS MOMENT BUT I
HOPE THAT WE CAN SEE RENEWAL ON
THE HORIZON IT IS EFFORTS. SUCH
AS OUR COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE
PERSIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
EFFORTS TO BRING ABOUT PEACE TO
BRING ABOUT A BETTER WORLD THAT
WILL HELP US OVERCOME AND I
HOPE THAT EACH OF US. CAN
REFLECT UPON THE MEANING OF NO
RUSE AS WE STRIVE FOR A NEW
DAY. A NO RUSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY WANT TO THANK MY
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FOR HELP US HONOR
THIS IMPORTANT HOLIDAY EVERY
YEAR I CAN'T ADD MUCH TO THE
ELOQUENT COMMENTS IN MY
COLLEAGUES BUT TO SAY THAT THIS
FEELS ALWAYS FEELS
APPROPRIATELY TIMED. I KNOW
RISK PARTICULARLY FOR OUR OUR
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR WHEN WE
ARE BEGINNING OUR NEW SESSION
IN EARNEST I KNEW DAY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN EARNEST WHEN WE
WORK TO. SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA SAID SO
BEAUTIFULLY IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THE WORLD RIGHT NOW THAT AS
WE ARE MERGED FROM THIS
PANDEMIC FROM ALL OF THIS
TERRIBLE SUFFERING. THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE AND RE
BIRTH AND SPRING AND ALL OF THE
THEMES OF THE HOLIDAY SO ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS SOMEONE WHICH EVERYONE
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AROUND
THE WORLD WHO ARE CELEBRATING A
NO LOSE MY VIDAK: I NOTICE
PROOF HEROES I HOPE IT IS ALL
THE BLESSINGS OF THE HOLIDAY
AND I STRONGLY URGE EVERYONE TO
VOTE. ON HR TWENTY. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU. NEHRU'S MARKS THE
TRADITIONAL. IRANIAN NEW YEAR
WHICH ORIGINATED IN ANCIENT
PERSIA. AND DATES BACK MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND YEARS. IT
OCCURRED ON THE RIVAL SPRING
AND SYMBOLIZES A TIME OF
RENEWAL. AND COMMUNITY. IT IS
CELEBRATED BY NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE WORLD. INCLUDING IN THE
UNITED STATES. AS THE HOLIDAY
OF SIGNIFICANCE AND
CELEBRATION. YOUR RAINY IN
AMERICANS OF ALL. NON RELIGIOUS
AND RELIGIOUS BACKGROUNDS
INCLUDING CHRISTIAN. JEWISH
MUSLIM THE RESTROOM. AND THE
HIGH. NO ROOM PROMOTES
COMPASSION FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS
AND UNITES PEOPLE OF MANY
FAITHS. NOWRUZ IS THE TIME TO
REMIND ALL AMERICANS OF THE
MANY CONTRIBUTIONS. OF THE
PERSIAN CIVILIZATION TO THE
WORLD AND THE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
FABRIC OF AMERICA. IRANIAN
AMERICANS CONTINUE TO MAKE
CONTRIBUTIONS IN ALL SECTORS OF
AMERICAN PUBLIC LIFE I DON'T OF
FIGHT AND ARE VITAL MEMBERS OF
THE AMERICAN FAMILY. WE WISH
ALL IRANIAN AMERICANS AND THOSE
WHO CELEBRATE NOWRUZ A VERY
HAPPY AND HEALTHY NEW YEAR. AND
SHARE WITH THEM WISHES FOR A
PEACEFUL AND HEALTHY START OF
THE SPRING SEASON I URGE IN
EITHER. THANK YOU MISS MORE
HORRID ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU ARE YOU RISE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT ABA A SOUND TONY
CELEBRATING APPROACH ON NEW
YORK NOR RULES. AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A SIXTY EIGHT
THE DISTRICT ARE. IN ORANGE
COUNTY ON WHEN A NORMAL INFO
COMES AROUND ALL WRONG- THIS
TIME. OVER TEN THOUSAND ALL. A
PERSON. MEMBERS GATHER IN
IRVINE NOW REGIONAL PARK GO TO
CELEBRATE ALL DAY LONG JUST SO
NORMAL SO ON NEW YEAR'S DAY AND
THEN ALSO THERE IS A SPECIAL
MEETING- BY THE US CITY HALL
PARKA. BILL BOB PARKER IN THE
ROSE GARDEN ARE CELEBRATING IN
THE BANDS HERE YOU KNOW ALL DAY
LONG AND THAT IS SO REALLY FUN
OF FALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
GET TOGETHER. AND TO CELEBRATE
THE PEACE AND HARMONY THAT I
EMPHASIZE SO FOR THROUGH SUCH.
REGIONAL CELEBRATIONS AS WELL
AS SAW ANY THAT ARE ROTTEN THE
CUSTOMER ABRASION OCCASIONS SO
AND ALL ALONG WITH OUR OUR OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE FLOOR AND
ALSO FOR THE MEMBERS. OF OUR
IRANIAN COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT ARE ARE I JOIN ALL
THIS ALL IMPORTANT NOTATION NO
RULE WITH AND THEN ALSO I SEE
YEAH. ON YOUR DESK OFF IN
CELEBRATION OF OUR- NO RULE
WITHOUT. THE OF CANDLELIGHT
THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN AS A GIFT I
THANK YOU FOR THAT THOUGH WE
CAN- A LIGHT THIS. CANDLE AND
THE CELEBRATE YEAH IN THE RULES
THOUGHT TOGETHER THANK YOU ARE
YOU WOULD YOU SUPPORT. A CHILD
TWENTY. THANK YOU DR JOINT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FOR
DEBATE THIS MEMBER IS THERE ANY
MAKE. THANK YOU JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR ELOQUENT COMMENTS AT A
TIME THAT WHEN THE WORLD NEEDS
IT AND CALIFORNIA NEEDS IT I
ALSO WANTED TO JUST SHARE THAT
THESE. CANDLES ARE. MOMENTO OF-
THOUGHT OF- ILLUMINATING YOUR
NEW YEAR AND- JUST TELL
EVERYONE HERE AND TO ALL
IRANIAN CALIFORNIANS IN THE
STATE NOTICE PETERS THANK YOU
ALL. THANK YOU MEMBERS WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE FOR COAL AUTHORS
THE CLERK WLL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE LEADERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CALL AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL THERE
ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOICE
VOTE FOR THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THE
CLOSELY NO. THE AYES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW BE MOVING
ON TO THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE ARE TWO
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. BEFORE WE VOTE WE
WILL TAKE UP THE FIRST
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. THE
COURT WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE TO
ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A
CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION. WE
CAN HEAR THE NAME. I THINK WE
MISSED THE BELL BUT THE ROLE IS
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION ON THIS- ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO ADD
YOUR NAME AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTION ON CONSENT PLEASE
VOTE NOW. CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS.
MOVING ON TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH TO PULL AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER MULLIN
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AGAIN WE SEEM
TO BE MISSING OUR BELL ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLOSE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WAS ADOPTED
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED. THE
FOLLOWING NUMBERS FOR GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN MEMORY.
MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR ADJOURN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS- AS WE CELEBRATE.
IRISH HERITAGE MONTH. THIS WEEK
I ASK THAT WE CLOSE IN THE
MEMORY OF A CALIFORNIA IRISHMAN
AN AMERICAN SON. ROBERT BRENDAN
GALLAGHER. MY GRANDFATHER.
ROBERT BOB GALLAGHER WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN TWENTY SIX INTO A
CALIFORNIA FARMING FAMILY. HE
WAS THE GRANDSON OF ANTHONY
GALLAGHER AN EARLY PIONEER TO
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF HIS EARLIEST
MEMORIES WAS HELPING OUT HIS
FATHER ED. AND GRANDFATHER ON
THE FAMILY FARM. HE REMEMBERED
HIS GRANDMOTHER MERRY ALLEN AS
BEING THE HEART OF THE FAMILY
ORCHESTRATING ALL THE DEMANDS
OF A FARMSTEAD IN PROVIDING FOR
THE NEEDS. FOR THE FAMILY AND
FARM HANDS. WHEN HE WAS YOUNG
HE BECAME VERY SICK AND IT WAS
HIS GRANDMOTHER WHO WAS BY HIS
BEDSIDE AND NURSED HIM BACK TO
HEALTH. BOB WAS ALWAYS VERY
ATHLETIC IN INTO SPORTS. HE
PLAYED FOOTBALL GOING ON TO
PLAY ON THE FRESHMAN SQUAD. FOR
ST MERRY'S GALLOPING GAELS. HIS
EDUCATION WAS CUT SHORT BY
WORLD WAR TWO LIKE MANY OF HIS
GENERATION HE ANSWERED THE CALL
AND JOINED THE ARMY AIR CORPS.
HIS FIRST STOP WAS DENVER
COLORADO AND IT WAS THERE THAT
HE MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
MERION BALLAST. THEY MET AT A
US SO DANCE HALL EVENT. MY
GRANDFATHER HAD GRIT AND
DETERMINATION IN SPADES.
ANAGRAM THAT DREW YOU AND. THAT
WAS ON FULL DISPLAY THAT NIGHT.
WHEN HE FOUND OUT THAT MY
GRANDMOTHER WAS ALREADY ENGAGED
TO ANOTHER HE TOLD HER FLAT OUT
TAKE THAT RING OFF YOUR FINGER
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO MARRY YOU.
THERE MUST TO WORK BECAUSE
SHORTLY THERE AFTER THEY WERE
MARRIED. AFTER THE WAR THEY
WERE OFF BACK TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE FAMILY FARM WHERE THEY
ESTABLISHED THEIR HOME AND
RAISE SEVEN CHILDREN. JUDY
ROBERTA DENNIS DIANE KELLY.
TRICK IN. TEN IT WAS A GOOD
LIFE ONE OF HARD WORK FAMILY
AND FUN BOB AND MARION LED TO
DANCE AND THEN WE GO TO THE
ROBINSON'S CORNER IN GRIDLEY
WITH THEIR FRIENDS FOR A NIGHT
OF DANCING. AFTER MARION BOB'S
GREATEST PASSION WAS BASEBALL.
HE COULD HIT EVERY PART OF THE
FIELD IT WAS AN EXCELLENT
CENTER FIELDER. HE PLAYED ON
SEVERAL SEMI PRO TEAMS LOCAL
TEAMS RETIRED WHEN HE WAS FORTY
YEARS OLD. THE YUBA CITY BEARS
TWIN CITIES GIANTS YUBA SUTTER
REBELS. AND HE SPENT MANY A
POSTGAME AT THE EAGLE'S NEST A
LOCAL GATHERING PLACE- THAT WAS
OWNED BY OUR VERY OWN DEBRA.
GRANDFATHER NICK FITS. AT THE
END OF HIS PLAYING CAREER. THE
TEAM'S HONORED HIM WITH THE BOB
GALLAGHER NIGHT AT BRYAN FIELD
IN MARYSVILLE. AND THE YEAR
BEFORE HE PASSED HE GOT TO
THROW OUT THE FIRST PITCH ON
THAT VERY SAME FIELD. PERHAPS
THE SECOND CLOSE. TO BASEBALL
WAS POLITICS. LIKE MANY IRISH
CATHOLICS. HE WAS BORN INTO A
FAMILY OF DEMOCRATS. BUT JUST
AS THE IRISH CAME OVER FROM
AMERICA BOB GALLAGHER BROUGHT
THE FAMILY OVER TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY. AN IRISHMAN
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS AS HE
LIKE TO SAY IT WAS PAT BROWN
THAT MADE HIM A REPUBLICAN. HE
VOTED. HE BELIEVED IN PUBLIC
SERVICE IN THE OBLIGATION TO
GIVE BACK. PROVIDING LEADERSHIP
ON THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD AND
EVENTUALLY BEING ELECTED TO THE
SUTTER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX. HE HELPED SPEARHEAD THE
SPEARHEAD THE FIRST CAMPAIGN.
OF OUR LONG TIME CONGRESSMAN
WALLY HERGER. A LIFELONG FRIEND
AND SERVED AS THE COUNTY
CHAIRMAN OF SUTTER COUNTY
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND THREE.
RECALL OF GRAY DAVIS. HE WAS MY
MENTOR IN SO MANY WAYS HE HAD
SOME GREAT SAYINGS LIKE. DON'T
PUT YOUR MOUTH IN GEAR BEFORE
YOU PUT YOUR BRAIN IN GEAR. I
STILL NEED TO LISTEN TO THAT
ONE. HE WOULD TELL ME THAT YOU
THAT YOU NEED TO BE GOOD AND
ABLE TO TALK ON YOUR FEET. AND
YOU WOULD ADMIT HE WAS NEVER
REALLY GOOD AT THAT. HE WAS A
MAN OF FEW WORDS. BUT HE MEANT
WHAT HE SAID AND HE SAID WHAT
HE MEANT. OVER THE YEARS HE
WELCOMED AS TREASURED GAS
PEOPLE OF ALL DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS. AND EVEN WITH THAT
AND EVEN WHEN THEY ARGUED WHICH
WAS OFTEN. HE KEPT THEM COMING
BACK FOR MORE. HE LOVED THIS
COUNTRY. HE WOULD ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE US NOT TO TAKE OUR
FREEDOMS FOR GRANTED. TO HONOR
OUR VETERANS AND THOSE WHO HAVE
GIVEN THEIR LIVES FOR LIBERTY.
ONE OF HIS FAVORITE PLACE IS A
TRAP TRIP TRAVEL IS BRANSON
MISSOURI BECAUSE OF THE MANY
PATRIOTIC SHOWS. AND THE BIG
BAND MUSIC THAT REMINDED HIM OF
HIS TIMES OF MY GRANDMOTHER. HE
BELIEVES IN TREATING A MAN
FAIRLY AND FIGHTING FOR A
RIGHTEOUS CAUSE. I THINK THAT'S
AN ESPECIALLY IRISH TRADE.
HANDED DOWN THROUGH THE
GENERATIONS MAYBE IT WAS
BECAUSE OF HOW MY ANCESTORS
WERE TREATED BACK IN IRELAND.
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO OWN LAND
AND WORK THE GROUND FOR A
PITTANCE. OR HOW WE WERE
TREATED WHEN WE FIRST CAME TO
AMERICA. MAYBE IT WAS BECAUSE
OF HIS GRANDMOTHER. HE TREATED
THOSE WHO WORK FOR HIM LIKE
FAMILY. AND UNDER HIS WATCH
EVERYONE PROSPERED AT THE
GALLAGHER RANCH. HE BELIEVED IN
EDUCATION MAY BECAUSE HE NEVER
GOT TO FINISH HIS. HE WOULD
HOUND US ALL THE TIME ABOUT
GETTING OUR DEGREE. TWO OF HIS
DAUGHTERS BECAME TEACHERS AND
EDUCATION LEADERS. HE LOVED HIS
FAMILY HE WAS PROUD OF ALL OF
HIS CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRAND CHILDREN AND
FOLLOWED ALL OF THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HIS FAVORITE
PLACE WAS ANYWHERE. THEY WERE
GATHERED. HE WAS STRONG. HE
PERSISTED THROUGHOUT VERSATILE
ON THE FARM AND HIS FAMILY HE
WAS THE ROCK THAT WE COULD
ALWAYS COUNT ON. FOR NINETY
FOUR YEARS A LIFE OF PURPOSE. A
LEGACY OF FAITH AND FAMILY. WE
WILL MISS HIM DEARLY BUT WE
KNOW THAT HE IS IN A PLACE
WHERE THE SUN SHINES UPON HIS
FACE. AND THE WIND IS ALWAYS AT
HIS BACK. KATE MILLER FOGGIA
GODSPEED TO OUR DEAR BOB.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS TREASURED MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION TO
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL CONTINUE WITH ADDITIONAL
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THIS
CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO HONOR
THE MEMORY OF GOD LOW THREE
VEDA A PROUD HUSBAND FATHER
GRANDFATHER AND LONG TIME
RESIDENT OF HIGHLAND PARK IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE.
CARLOS WAS BORN IN RURAL
MICHIGAN IN NINETEEN FIFTY S.
ONE OF TEN CHILDREN. HIS FAMILY
WORKED IN THE FIELDS AND ON
DAIRY FARMS HE WAS EIGHTEEN
WHEN HE WAS EIGHTEEN CARLOS
JOINED THE UNITED STATES
AIRFORCE AND WAS STATIONED IN
THE UNITED KINGDOM WHERE HE MET
HIS WIFE LYNN. ULTIMATELY THEY
DECIDED TO SETTLE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I WAS BEGAN HIS
LIFE WITH VERY LITTLE PUBLIC
RESILIENCE HE BUILT AN AMAZING
LIFE AND LET AT HOME IN LIFE
FOR HIMSELF IN THE FAMILY. HE
EMBODIED EVERY PART OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM. HE IS DESCRIBED
BY HIS FAMILY AS A REMARKABLE
MAN KNOWN TO. KNOWN TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT EVERYTHING AND
EFFORTLESSLY NAVIGATE
CONVERSATIONS FROM BASEBALL TO
HISTORY TO BOXING TO POLITICS
AND WORLD AFFAIRS. I GOT A
CHANCE TO SPEND TIME WITH HIM
AT A DODGERS VERSUS GIANTS GAME
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN I THREW
THE FIRST PITCH HE AND HIS SON
JARED WHO IS PART OF MY LONG
TIME S. YEAH YOU FAMILY.
CHEERED ME ON THAT WAS A REALLY
GOOD DAY. CARLOS WITH AN
AMAZING FATHER AND WAS ALWAYS
THERE WHEN YOU NEEDED HIM HE
ADORED HIS GRANDCHILDREN. FROM
METAL AND FILL LAST DECEMBER
DURING A DIFFICULT TIME FOR
MANY DUE TO THE DEVASTATING
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
KERR KARLA'S PASS FROM HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS IN HIS HOME
SURROUNDED BY FAMILY HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS SIBLINGS. HIS
TWO SONS JARED AND JORDAN AND
HIS GRANDCHILDREN. CARLOS WILL
ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED AS A
FAMILY MAN A PILLAR OF HIS
COMMUNITY AND AN EXAMPLE TO
FOLLOW. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF GODLESS YOU BETTA AND
HIS LOVE FOR COMMUNITY AND
FAMILY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITH REAL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
YOUR RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY BECAUSE MY CITY HAS
LOST A VERY BRIGHT LIGHT. AN
INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY ADVOCATE
AND A LEADER WHO SHAPE SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BAY AREA INTO
WHAT THEY ARE TODAY. AND HOSTED.
BORN IN WEST VIRGINIA DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. GROWING UP IN
THE MIDWEST BEFORE GRADUATING
FROM DUKE SHE MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR WHERE SHE BEGAN HER
LIFELONG QUEST TO BUILD
COMMUNITY. THROUGH IMPROVING
OUR ENVIRONMENT BRIDGING
CULTURAL DIVIDES AND ADVANCING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN. MANY
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S GREAT
NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS- THEIR
EXISTENCE TO AN- SHE WAS A
CHARTER MEMBER OF THE OPEN
SPACES COMMITTEE WHERE SHE WAS
APPOINTED BY THEN MAYOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN. FOR GUIDANCE ON OUR
CITY'S NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS
COUNCIL. HAS INSPIRED THE
UPKEEP OF OUR CITIES PARKS AND
GREENERY TODAY. IF YOU EVER
HAVE A CHANCE TO TAKE A WALK
DOWN SAN FRANCISCO OF WORLD
FAMOUS WATERFRONT. YOU'LL ALSO
SEE ANN'S LEGACY. AS A
METROPOLITAN FROM
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSIONER AND
A MEMBER OF THE NORTHWEST.
WATERFRONT ADVISORY GROUP AND
TRANSFORM THE EMBARCADERO PARK
BOULEVARD RESTORED THE FERRY
BUILDING HELPED CONCEIVE THE
BOOK OF THE BLUE GREEN WAY. SHE
WAS ALSO AN INCREDIBLE CHAMPION
FOR WOMEN. SHE FOUGHT FOR
GENDER EQUITY IN OUR WORK IN
HUMAN RESOURCES WHERE SHE
WORKED TO CHANGE CORPORATE
CULTURE FROM WITHIN. SHE SPENT
YEARS SUPPORTING FEMALE
POLITICIANS ON THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S CAMPAIGN FUND BOARD.
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
APTLY RECOGNIZED HER AS ONE OF
THE WOMAN. WHO COULD BE
PRESIDENT. I GOT TO KNOW WHEN
WE SERVED TOGETHER ON THE BOARD
OF THE CHINATOWN COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CENTER. SHE WAS AN
AMAZING BRIDGE BUILDER BETWEEN
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. SUCH
SO THAT MANY OF US CONSIDER HER
TO BE AN HONORARY MEMBER OF OUR
CHINESE COMMUNITY. BUT MORE
BROADLY SHE WAS A LEADER. IF I
WERE TO READ THE NAMES OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SHE LED. IT
WOULD TAKE AN HOUR. JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES SHE WAS A SAN
FRANCISCO REDEVELOPMENT
COMMISSIONER. SHE WAS PRESIDENT
OF OUR CITY'S PORT COMMISSION.
VICE CHAIR OF THE BAY
CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. AND SPENT TWELVE
YEARS ON THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. IN
HER ORAL HISTORY CAPTURED BY
THE UC BANCROFT LIBRARY. AND
SAID THAT SHE PURSUED FREE
THEMES TO IMPROVE COMMUNITY. TO
FIND ISSUES THAT BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER. TO MAXIMIZE DIVERSITY
AND PROBLEM SOLVING AND TO
BUILD ALLIANCES WITHIN
COMMUNITY. IF THIS BODY PURSUED
ALL OF THOSE THINGS OUR STATE
WOULD BE A FAR BETTER PLACE.
LET ME END BY SAYING WHAT I
WILL MISS THE MOST ABOUT OUR
FRIEND IN. IS OUR COMMITMENT TO
JUSTICE. HER MODESTY AND HUMBLE
SPIRIT. FOR ABILITY TO LEAD
WITHOUT EGO. FOR ALL OF US WHO
KNEW HER HER SPIRIT WILL LIVE
ON IN SO MANY NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES I WANT EXPRESS MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO OUR
PARTNER WAS WITH ME. HER
EXTENDED FAMILY OF MANY FRIENDS
ALLIES AND SUPPORTERS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
JOURNAL HER MEMORY. REST IN
PEACE AND- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MMORY. THEY HAVE A
SPEAKER I ALSO WANT TO RISE AND
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF AND HALLSTATT- I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DID AN AMAZING JOB
REALLY RECITING. ALL THE
DIFFERENT ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT
SHE HAS. DONE MADE. THERE'S
REALLY NOT A BOARD THERE'S NOT
AN ORGANIZATION. THAT SHE WAS
NOT INVOLVED IN THAT DIDN'T
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE LAND USE
AND THE SKYLINE OF OUR AMAZING
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. IN FACT
SHE WAS ALWAYS THE ONE THE REAL
CITIZEN WHO WAS CONSTANTLY
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES UP TO
THE MOMENT THAT SHE PASSED AWAY.
I BELIEVE THAT SHE WAS ALWAYS
THE CITIZEN THAT WAS- THE GO TO
PERSON ON THESE ISSUES BECAUSE
SHE WAS TIRELESS. SHE WORKED
NONSTOP HER DESIRE TO MAKE A
CHANGE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CITY- WAS ALWAYS. MOVING
FORWARD WAS ALWAYS ABLE TO
BUILD BE YET WAS PRESERVING ARE
VERY PRECIOUS NEIGHBORHOODS I
CAN REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME I
HAD. COFFEE WITH HER AND HER
HUSBAND WELLS AND IS VERY
APPROPRIATE AT A COFFEE SHOP IN
NORTH BEACH IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT THEY WERE CONSTANTLY.
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT
THAT NORTH BEACH COMMUNITY WAS
PRESERVED AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THE REST OF THE CITY WAS
ALLOWED TO GROW. SHE IS SOMEONE
WHO IS THE ULTIMATE SAN
FRANCISCO CITIZENS. SHE WILL
DEFINITELY BE MISSED. SHE'S
SOMEONE WHO HAS A LEGACY COMES
FROM- FORTY TO SIXTY YEARS OF
OUR TIRELESS WORK. AND FOR THAT
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY I FOUND HOSTED. THANK
YOU MISTER KING MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DEATH TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
pMEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER. THE SEVEN SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH
NINETEENTH NO FLOOR SESSION NO
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY MARCH
TWENTY SECOND FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER OBJECTION OR BUSINESS I
AM READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MR GABRIEL MOVES AND
MR GALLAGHER SECONDS OF THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH TWENTY SECOND AT
ONE PM.